right now we bring in former Speaker of
the House Fox News contributor Newt
Gingrich
um I think America will tolerate a day
or two of some infighting and a little
back and forth and a little squabbling
here's what I don't understand if we
already know where McCarthy stands on in
terms of Investigations he's going to
investigate the FBI the doj he's going
to investigate the origins of covet the
withdrawal from Afghanistan and also Joe
Biden himself and the money that he and
his family made and whether they sold
access on the commitments to America's
side he's laid out a very specific
agenda then you have the motion to
vacate that he's agreed to with only
five members needed to get it started so
that seems like an insurance policy to
me why such resistance
you know I I can't explain it I
understand that you could have one or
two or three people who are crazy but
the fact that you had 19 people vote
three times and then Byron Donald's
joined them uh on the grounds that he
didn't have the votes yet uh but even
then that means you have 20 people
voting against not they're not voting
against McCarthy they're voting against
the house Republican conference the
conference was ten to one in favor of
McCarthy on the floor he got 85 percent
of the vote when there was above between
he and Andy Gibbs in the conference
itself as to who should be the speaker
and these people are taking on their
shoulders setting a standard that any
five members of that conference could go
out and Destroy Everything You Know
Lincoln in his first inaugural warned
that the problem of secession is once
you establish that principle then
everybody can secede from everybody
these five people need to take a deep
breath tonight and ask themselves are
they really want to send a signal that
every five people in the conference can
screw up everything for whatever reason
and believe me I know from personal
conversations that last night
there were three of them went in and
presented Kevin McCarthy with 30 some
different demands most of them involving
personal advancement I mean they aren't
talking about ideology they weren't
talking about principles they're talking
about who gets which committee who gets
to be chairman things that clearly are
an effort to Blackmail all of the rest
of the conference
and I think the rest of the conference
understands this is a core decision
do the 202 win or do the 20 win and in a
free Society you cannot just as you
can't give in to terrorists and you
can't give in to hostage takers you
can't allow them to take the conference
hostage and win I hope that in a
conference tomorrow morning when people
have had a good night's sleep have a
chance to talk
I hope they can find some key policy not
not patronage a key policy position
that'll bring back enough of the members
to get this over with on the first
ballot tomorrow I'm personally not all
that shaken we had nine ballots to pick
a speaker in 1923. we had 133 ballots to
pick a speaker in 1855. so this is not
unprecedented and even in the case of
Pelosi she had to negotiate with people
get several of them to vote president
and stay out of the way so you know the
currently this is not a disaster but if
these people don't take seriously their
responsibility to their colleagues not
to Kevin but to their colleagues in the
conference then I think it could grow
into a disaster and Kevin has a lot of
people he represents here you have oh
why do you got 203 votes earlier today
and he needs 218. now the question is
you're right are they what exactly are
they Holding Out for I've been asking
people and talking to some members and
those who are that were telling me they
were going to oppose Kevin I said okay
what is it that you want why don't you
meet with them why don't you make a list
I can't tell you how often I heard
nothing back from them or if I heard one
thing and then came Kevin said yes to it
like for example in in the case of a
motion to vacate then the bar got higher
then the bar shifted then the bar
changed at what point does does the
American people and Republicans around
the country
say they've had enough with this
somebody said to me well this is this is
a great exercise of a Democratic
Republic in action and Americans will be
inspired by it uh I said I beg to differ
I think they're going to get sick and
tired of this pretty fast
look I I think a number of these uh
so-called insurgents whatever you want
to call them
are actually putting their re-election
at risk right now because people are
going to look up and say you know how
can you hold the entire party hostage
how can you hold the house hostage who
do you think you are to have this kind
of authority and I I had talked with
Kevin early on and said just be aware
excuse me the last night
they will come in with a whole new set
they came in last night with 30
additional demands 30. now that's that
says I'm going to vote no but I want to
tease you I want to play with you and I
think it's pretty insulting to every
member of the conference who stayed with
Kevin so you have a 203 to 20 uh Choice
here and and most free societies 203 is
a bigger number than 20. I'm not sure
the 20 understand that yet but maybe by
tomorrow they will
all right we'll see Mr speaker thank you
for being with us hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else